[Music]
travel tips
let's talk about him I've traveled to a
lot of places specially in the last 10
years something like 40 plus countries
and I have learned a lot about what
works for me at least so I'll share a
few of them number one for earplugs the
best I have found max M ACK apostrophe s
silicone earplugs these are not foam you
don't roll them up and stick them in
your ear you actually effectively
plaster them over the ear and I was
introduced to these by competitive
swimmers what's really nice about these
a they block more sound based as far as
I can perceive secondly you can sleep on
your side or something like that they do
not come out and they do not poke
further into your ear so I'm a big big
fan of these earplugs and I have them in
every bag that I might travel with
so I've redundancy there next is a ball
rub this big looks like a golf ball with
tiny little points on it are you busy
and this is for rolling out your feet
before you travel and when you land so
let's say you get to a hotel air B&B
whatever it might be
first thing take off the shoes we're all
out your feet and this tends to prevent
and alleviate a lot of tension not only
in the legs and hips but also in the
back for whatever reason tip pro tip if
you have the option get a massage say
the date after you land not the day you
land for reasons we won't get into right
now and focus on cervical neck and upper
spine and that can also dramatically
reduce or remove any type of back
soreness and so on that was incurred
through travel next tip I always have
two particular items for immune function
or supporting immune function
I have sprayable zinc and there are many
different types that you can use which
I'll use probably three or four times on
days of travel also I will travel with
one gram capsules or tablets of vitamin
C and while I am traveling I'll take one
gram every hour that I am awake and
there's a lot so used to gut tolerance
as they would say in other words don't
make yourself who in your pants does
master pants no bueno so you might want
to test that before you're on an
airplane and then last this is perhaps
the the coup de Gras one of my favorite
discoveries in the last five or six
years and it is travel caching what is
caching me that is from cache not cache
money but CA CH e right and this means
that for the locations I visit most
often if you look at travel patterns
let's just say for me within the United
States very often I'm flying to the same
places maybe 80 90 percent of the time
New York City let's say Miami whatever
it might be I will develop a
relationship with a particular hotel all
these hotels have storage then what I
will do is for the weather in that
particular city I will have seven to ten
days worth of clothing including any
type of say outerwear for New York City
in the winter one jacket will do one or
two pairs of shoes say sneakers for
walking and then something that equates
to business casual or for something a
little more fancy and it lives in New
York City it stays there all the time
how does this work well I can walk to
the airport use a clear card which I use
for everything and I became an adviser
to the company after many years of using
it which will get me from walking in the
door of the airport to the gate usually
in say six or seven minutes it's
incredibly effective for skipping
security lines clear card and then I
walk in no luggage maybe a backpack with
a laptop and that's it I land in New
York I have everything that I need then
at the end of the trip I'll also even
include say-so coconut oil or almond
butter and sardines and cans that's
picked up from Dominick D'Agostino a
scientist so I have even food if I write
if I arrive late at night or simply
don't deal with room service I even have
some food that's not likely to expire
I wear this clothing for say a week and
then I pack it up or I don't pack it up
I just leave it in the room and because
I am a frequent visitor at the hotel I
asked them to do wash and fold or clean
out of the hotel pack it up put it back
in my trunk they'll often even give you
a trunk to use you can buy one for 50
bucks but I was given a trunk it's not
because they know who I am it's because
I've developed a relationship and it's
cheap for them to help anyway and they
will wash fold the clothing put it back
in your trunk lock it up put it in
storage and then it's ready for use the
next time it's fantastic and so you have
that not everywhere okay so it's maybe a
few hundred bucks that you spend and
it's in one or two locations meaning one
or two cities and you have everything
that you need you do not need to pack a
single thing and it's recycled and ready
for use the next time you go there that
is a long-term investment of course it's
not for everybody but for the cost of
one or two plane tickets you can never
pack luggage or never have to pack
luggage again to your two most common
destinations it's for me at least an
incredibly incredibly fantastic return
on investment and has made my travel
life infinitely easier and more
enjoyable so those are a few tips you
can take and run with good luck and
happy traveling
you